le coût de cette guerre est élevé mais
céder à cette agression serait plus
coûteux si nous laissons faire
soit nous soutenons les ukrainiens qui
défendent leur pays
soit nous restons à l'écart tandis que
les russes continuent leurs agressions
et leurs atrocités en ukraine chaque
jour les ukrainiens paye ce combat
auprès de leur vie
donc nous devons contribuer avec des
armes des fonds des munitions avec ce
soutien économique faire en sorte que
leur courage et leurs sacrifices ne
soient pas vains qu'il puisse continuer
ce combat et faire ce qu'ils ont à faire
il est fondamental que ce financement
soit approuvée le plus vite possible
et on retrouve sonia dridi washington
sonia bonsoir joe biden fait monter les
enchères sur un ton plutôt offensif
oui et le soutien américain s'amplifie
de façon assez spectaculaire le soutien
médical ukraine joe biden a déclaré au
début de son discours aider l'ukraine
coûte cher mais les états unis ne
peuvent pas rester sans rien faire le
président américain qui demande au
congrès d'approuver une aide
supplémentaire de 33 milliards de
dollars pour le cren dont plus de 20
milliards dead militaire quelques 3
milliards d aide humanitaire et puis
environ 8 milliards dead économique
notamment pour soutenir le gouvernement
ukrainien pour qu'ils puissent continuer
de distribuer les salaires les retraites
maintenir les écoles ouvertes selon
l'administration américaine est bien
cette aide est nécessaire pour permettre
à l'ukraine de faire face au pendant les
cinq prochaines mois les cinq prochains
mois de la guerre la maison blanche part
du principe que cette guerre va durer
encore longtemps joe biden qui a demandé
au congrès d'approuver au plus vite
cette aide alors il devrait pas y avoir
de soucis puisque
il y à une rare unité au congrès un des
élus républicains et démocrates dans ce
dossier de la cré guerre en ukraine
depuis le début de l'invasion russe en
ukraine on l'a vu au départ les états
unis et bien et se cantonner à une aide
avec des armes plutôt vu comme
défensives pour l'ukraine est désormais
ils envoient de l'artillerie lourde des
hélicoptères des drones les etats unis
qui joue un don à un jeu d'équilibriste
parce qu'ils ont dit répété qu'ils ne
voulaient pas envoyer de troupes sur le
terrain et donc il se concentre sur
l'aide militaire joe biden qui dans ce
discours a tenu encore à préciser nous
n'attaquons pas la russie nous aidons
l'ukraine à ce défense à se défendre
face à laval invasion russe et
rapidement un sonia sur la menace
nucléaire joe biden a affirmé que
c'était irresponsable que d'agiter cette
menace
oui tout à fait joe biden qui répondait
à la question d'un journaliste à savoir
que le cred faut que pour la russie ce
conflit est de plus en plus un conflit
avec les états unis joe biden a dit que
les etats-unis étaient prêts à tout et
il a dit que c'est est irresponsable de
la part de la russie d'agiter la menace
nucléaire joe biden qui est aussi dans
ce discours a rendu un hommage appuyé
aux journalistes qui sont sur le terrain
en ukraine il a dit imaginer ce que ce
serait si on n'avait pas toutes ces
informations ce serait un monde
différent merci beaucoup sonia sonia
dridi en direct de washington